from jon favreau the guy who went from
playing Mike in swingers to becoming one
of today's best directors to one of the
worst to one of the best again unum
comes the year's best film about talking
animals you must be the very one five
members team which is really saying
something because there's been like 10
of them already and the years not even
done yet
the Jungle Book Disney is remaking all
their Animated Classics into live-action
movies and Jungle Book was next on the
spreadsheet so pull up your red diver
and join the pack for this well-written
visually stunning action-packed movie
with great characters look I'm not gonna
lie
this thing is way better than it deserve
to be you remembered loving the original
animated Jungle Book even though it's
really not that good now they're giving
a new twist to an old classic
this one has a plot follow a law on a
young man's search for acceptance in
this winning combination of The Lion
King
a Ben Kingsley nature documentary Milo
of the jungle drinking cognitive for
eats and a kid-friendly version of the
revenant cheese out there's no deleted
scene where he sleeps inside of a rhino
watch yourself please journey deep
inside a downtown Los Angeles blue
screen studio where a grown man spent
months playing with a little boy in his
underwear that they turned into this
holy crap
there you'll meet Mowgli a park or
loving orphan MacGyver who must leave
the safety of his family to escape Shere
Khan a scary tiger so now you know fear
Khan will do whatever it takes to keep
his jungle safe even if it turns him
into a monster while Mowgli will prove
Shere Khan right by using man's
destructive fire to stop him so wait
which one's wrong this is a lot of death
for a kid's movie
and her a whole new world of Hollywood
a-listers pretending to be animals who
act just like those same Hollywood
a-listers like Balu a lovable old Bill
Murray tight no need to get worked up
King Louie a giant egg who appears
whenever you played the cowbell kind of
like Christopher Walken and CAW a boa
constrictor with sexy exposition eyes
who proves that whether she's playing a
killer alien a fancy iPod or a giant
snake Scarlett Johansson's voice will
still probably turn you on would you
like to see enjoy a remake that didn't
just improve on the original story
they also cherry-pick the only two good
songs then for some reason give a
classic like bare necessities to two
people who can barely see and turn I
want to be like you and to a Christopher
Walken solo number what we do I'm gonna
be like you and we all know how that
turns out they can make us sound good
you know it's kind of a miracle so strap
in for a movie full of incredible sets
photorealistic animals and a word in a
groundbreaking definitive version of the
story it's impossible to talk but Warner
Brothers and Andy Serkis are gonna try
in 2018 anyway because God forbid a CGI
movie come out that doesn't include
Andy Serkis I am
Hey hey guys you know sometimes it's
okay to just you know like not make a
movie starring one real boy
a bunch of random guys in blue body
suits other guys in motion capture
leotards cute little hand puppets giant
creepy puppet heads even creepier
puppeteers hahaha a log some grass
flat-screen monitors very temporary CGI
Jon Favreau pretending to be a bear and
a whole lot of lives grade jungle book
to the wrath of Shere Khan
so I know he mentioned it when we did
the original but Jungle Book 2 is
totally gonna set up tailspin right
please be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers hey screen junkies do
you wish all your favorite movies had an
awesome and credit scene then check out
the latest batch of all new after
credits our exclusive animated series
with how it should have ended click the
box on the left to see our after credits
scene for Jurassic world and check out
even more exclusively on screen junkies
calm and don't forget Emmy voters this
is your last week to vote for us to win
best short form variety series so share
the box on the ride and help us bring
home sweet Emmy gold now let's read some
dumb comments and show those TV Academy
members what they're voting for how the
hell we got nominated for a Emmy hit him
with the hide I'm Rick and this is my
pawn shop
honey where are my socks Humpty Dumpty
sat on a wall Humpty Dumpty had a great
fall all the king's horses and all the
king's men had scrambled eggs for dinner
the evil squirrel has my hairdryer I
must find that golden asparagus Steve